when you did that scorsese must've been
a thrill to get a call from scorsese
top of the mountain that's the one with
jonah hill right and you're doing a
scene with him and you're the guy on
wall street who actually punches jonah
hill in the face
and scorsese says look this doesn't look
real i want you to punch jonah right in
the [ __ ] face
so they tell you to punch him in the
face did you punch him so hard in the
face that he broke his teeth
oh look jonah's a great guy and i have a
ton of respect for him
but i i heard tell him i heard him tell
that story on your show
and that was a
[Music]
a slap okay you know i just let me slap
you and as soon as
the scene's over slap me back off camera
you can smack the [ __ ] out of me right
you know like
tit for tat i get and i always offer
that to people but i think we should do
it for real it's it's [ __ ] scorsese
let me do a fake like kid kid punt you
know anyway she's got a director de niro
you know come on man and and uh and and
and you know jonah he just
uh he it it wasn't something he was
totally into at the time and
and you know we kept talking and it's
true you know it really wasn't working
and then i think it was really leo who
who sort of stepped up and said
you know i think you guys should do it
for real and and jonah you know he'd be
he he was brave man he said okay you
know this is going to be the real punch
everybody
and i want everyone to be ready you know
they're ready with like an ice pack and
[ __ ] like that
right and uh you know i figured if
you're only gonna you know it's sort of
a trick of the trade of
stunt guys who i have the most respect
for you just make sure you do it once
like do it right
get it right make sure they get it on
film so yeah so we i made sure it was it
was good
he broke his teeth it's his fake teeth
you dress like [ __ ]
so [ __ ]